we're at Le'Veon gymnasium at Columbia
University and we're here to play the
annual Columbia community service
charity basketball event.
What we do is, we run a campaign where we try to
gain a certain amount of money from our
employees so that we can give it out to
different agencies throughout the
throughout the Harlem community. Our goal
is always to raised about three hundred
and fifty thousand a year, we've been the
last three years we've been making our
goal and we've been able to provide
monies to different organizations
organizations that do everything from
after-school programs,
senior citizen programs, Food Pantry-- I
can go down the list.
It's always great to get out here with the colleagues the
guys and the girls and see you know what
people can do outside of the desk. It's
it's always fun to get out here and play.
It gives you another purpose, yeah,
when you play for charity they've been
playing the summer for the last five
years six years since I've been at the University
There's a lot of enthusiasm
because they enjoy you know getting
together and competing against their
fellow employees as well as having an
opportunity to raise money for Columbia
community service